[Music]
if you're a data-driven enterprise
you've likely been met with an explosion
of data growth in recent years and need
to find the best way to store all your
terabytes and petabytes at scale Google
Cloud Storage allows worldwide storage
and retrieval of any amount of data at
any time you can use Google Cloud
Storage for a range of scenarios
including serving website content
storing data for archival and disaster
recovery or distributing large data
objects to users via direct download in
this hands-on lab cloud storage
QuickStart console you will learn how to
use the Google cloud platform console to
create a storage bucket then upload
objects create folders and subfolders
and make those objects publicly
accessible data doesn't just mean rows
and columns and numbers anymore you may
want to store unstructured data like
messages documents multimedia files
webpages and so on whatever your storage
requirements are security availability
and cost will be your three
considerations Cloud Storage aims to
meet all of these requirements next up
on our quest is cloud I am QuickStart
[Music]